um 10 uhr geht der prozess im mordfall
walter lübke weiter im fokus steht der
sohn den er hatte damals seinen vater
tot aufgefunden
schwerer gang für familie lübke vor
gerichte sohn jan hendrik soll heute als
zeuge aussagen er hatte seinen
erschossenen vater im juni 2009 10 auf
der terrasse seines hauses gefunden laut
anklage soll stephan ernsting kasseler
regierungspräsidenten weiter lübke aus
rechtsextremistischen motiven per
kopfschuss getötet haben
wegen beihilfe zum mord angeklagt ist
marcus h bei den ermittlungen wurde auch
das handy von jan henrich lübke
ausgewertet und chat verläufe aus der
zeit vom januar 2015 bis zur mordnacht
ausgelesen dabei fanden die ermittler
auch zwei seltsame nazi posts mit den
gespeicherten bildschirmfotos hatte der
sohn den hass der seinem vater im netz
entgegenschlug dokumentiert und ihm
geraten die polizei einzuschalten
dabei war auch ein video auf dem eine
unbekannte männliche person auf einer
feier den hitlergruß zeigt im
hintergrund ist das schon von der
wehrmacht genutzte falsche mega lied zu
hören
der hauptangeklagte stefan ernst hatte
vor polizei und ermittlungsrichter
bereits zwei geständnisse abgelegt die
allerdings unterschiedlicher nicht sein
könnten
im juni 2009 10 hatte er den mord
gestanden später die tat dann widerrufen
im januar 2020 sagte der neonazi
schließlich aus markus h habe walter
lübke aus versehen getötet
am donnerstag will sich stefan ernst nun
vor gericht umfassend schriftlich
einlassen und lisa ködert verfolgt für
uns den prozess guten morgen lisa was
wird denn heute erwartet ja man darf
gespannt sein wie die vernehmung von
walter lübke ältestem sohn jan hendrik
heute verläuft sicherlich werden diese
videos ein thema sein die auf dem handy
gefunden wurden
es ist noch unklar wo diese herkommen es
wurde ja herausgefunden wer diese
verschickt hat allerdings könnte es gut
sein dass diese videos auch daher
stammen dass der älteste sohn von walter
lübcke jahr aktiv recherchiert hat nach
dem so viel hass und hetze im internet
gegen seinen vater walter lübcke
aufgekommen ist und er damit freunden
auch
momente zusammengetragen hat das könnte
eine erklärung für die videos seien
allerdings ist das völlig unklar demnach
ist es natürlich an der
staatsanwaltschaft und an den richtern
das jetzt herauszufinden
aber es gibt ja auch noch etwas von
gestern zu klären was ist gestern
passiert ja gestern kam es zu einem
eklat wegen der anwälte von dem
angeklagten stefan ernst und zwar sind
die sich offenbar sehr uneinig was die
verteidigungsstrategie angeht da hatte
nämlich frank hannig einer der anwälte
von stefan ernst plötzlich einen antrag
gestellt der wohl nicht abgesprochen war
er kam dann mit einem einbruch in das
kasseler regierungspräsident daher bei
dem offenbar aktien verschwunden sein
sollten
bei denen es um die familie lücke und
die söhne auch ging und um geschäfte er
wollte mit diesem antrag wohl die
familie lücke schlecht dastehen lassen
quasi den eindruck erwecken dass die
familie lücke in schmutzige geschäfte
geschäfte verwickelt wäre der andere
anwalt von stefan ernst wollte dies aber
auf keinen fall mittragen und hat dann
einen antrag gestellt dass der andere
anwalt von stefan ernst quasi sein
mandat niederlegen sollte das heißt es
könnte sein dass jetzt um 10 uhr hier
sofort frank hannig also der zweite
verteidiger von stefan ernst hier aus
dem gebäude raus kommt weil er sein
mandat nicht weiter erfüllen soll weil
auch laut stefan ernst und seinem
anderen verteidiger wie gesagt recht
kompliziert weil sie nicht einverstanden
sind mit dieser verteidigungsstrategie
weil man der familie lücke nicht schaden
welt mit der verteidigungsstrategie
dankeschön lisa gödert live aus
frankfurt